hey youtubers it's Charlie so huge news
everyone's freaking out Robert Downey
jr. has just been cast in Captain
America 3 this is gonna be a breakdown
of what's going on and behind the scenes
because apparently it caused some big
problems behind the scenes at Marvel it
actually took a lot of negotiating and
at one point he was cut out of the movie
then put back in so there's a lot of
drama
hello to any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
Marvel and DC videos every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything
so first things first here's what we
know about the movie itself the two big
titles that they're working on adapting
are civil war and fallen Sun obviously
Iron Man and Captain America 2 very
important characters to those stories
fallen Sun is essentially the follow-up
to Civil War just to explain things a
little bit better I have to get into
minor spoilers for the comics so if you
want to you can just mute the audio
until the spoiler tag goes away
everybody ready okay here we go
Civil War splits the Marvel Universe
over the idea of superhero Registration
the government wants everyone to
register their secret identities they
kind of did this in the x-men movie
universe with the mutant Registration
it's the same idea
Captain America takes the people side
and says no everyone does not need to
give up their identities Iron Man takes
the side of the government remembers
Stark Enterprises gets a shitload of
money from the government so obviously
Tony Stark being the capitalist is gonna
side with the money big battle goes down
eventually Captain America gets
assassinated there's like a whole
separate plot going on with that that
deals with the Red Skull it's not super
important for this story right now
fallen Sun the other story that they're
thinking about adapting for the movie is
the follow-up to Civil War it just deals
with the aftermath of Captain America's
death obviously we all know Captain
America comes back to life and it
involves his big time travel storyline
but it is an interesting way for them to
invoke the time gem I know obviously
that gem has to come into the Marvel
Universe at some point that's what the
story the movie is supposed to be here's
the story of what's going on with Robert
Downey jr. in the movie originally it
was planned for him to have a brief
cameo but Robert Downey jr. wanted a
bigger part they changed the story but
because he ended up being a much bigger
part of it they had to pay him a lot
more money and the Marvel executives
like the ones that sign the cheques did
not want to do that so they ordered him
to be written out of them
Kevin Feige president of Marvel Studios
argued to get him back in and eventually
Robert Downey jr. is people Kevin Feige
and Marvel Studios came to an agreement
that agreement amounts to about 40
million dollars in pay that is a lot of
money yes the thought that they're using
to justify at that payday is that by
putting Robert Downey jr. in the movie
it'll boost the box office gross
immensely so they'll make their money
back or at least that's what they're
hoping obviously before all this happens
though Avengers age of Ultron has to go
down and the idea is that the fallout
from that movie will be where all this
chaos starts Ultron's supposed to crush
the Avengers so obviously he's going to
be destroying a lot of people it's that
chaos that will probably create the rift
in the Avengers supposedly Captain
America is not supposed to be in
Avengers 3 if the Avengers do have a
falling out after age of Ultron and
Captain America 3 turns into civil war
that could explain why he's not going to
be in Avengers 3 the funny thing is is
that by putting Robert Downey jr. in
Captain America it essentially turns it
into a pseudo Avengers type movie I mean
he's too big of a character for it to
just be about Chris Evans there's also
been a lot of rumors that the cast of
Avengers 3 won't involve most of the
main Avengers it'll be like an alternate
roster the Civil War storyline in the
comics leaves this big void and
essentially a new team of Avengers comes
in it's a whole separate plot that turns
into Dark Reign and Dark Avengers but
essentially the normal Avengers are all
scattered off until they form Secret
Avengers it gets really complicated but
basically all the normal Avengers aren't
going to be Avengers anymore the people
that are writing Captain America 3 are
also in talks to direct Avengers 3 so it
makes sense that the Captain America 3
Civil War storyline will directly
crossover with Avengers 3 like Avengers
3 will be the follow-up to Civil War so
essentially what you have is you have
two Avengers in a non Avengers movie
lots of money being thrown around lots
of drama behind the scenes I think it'll
be really interesting
the real question though is that how are
they going to deal with the civil war
storyline in the comics like how are
they going to alter that a lot of the
characters like spider-man belong to
other franchises spider-man is a big
character in civil war I know there have
been a lot of talks about Sony including
him in Avengers 3 that's still possible
but I'm not going to make any theories
about it
I see something definite Tony Stark at
his core though is a character that's
all about control controlling his
environment with technology so it's
possible that they'll use the age of
miracles so to speak or mutants or
whatever they want to call it inside the
Marvel Universe as the MacGuffin for
superhero registration so what does all
this mean for Chris Evans Robert Downey
jr. obviously Robert Downey jr. has a
separate contract he's not on like the
six movie contract that everyone else is
on Chris Evans only has one more movie
after Captain America 3 so if he sits
out Avengers 3 that'd give him one more
movie he'd be able to retake the mantle
in a future movie Robert Downey jr. is
ahold of the story in his own words he
said he is going to ride the superhero
wave into the shore that just means he's
gonna stay inside the Marvel Universe as
long as they'll keep making deals with
him he's their biggest expense right now
so making deals with him is probably one
of the hardest things for them to do and
when you make deals that are that big it
gets way more complicated legally and
financially so if you ever wonder why
Marvel just doesn't announce everything
at comic-con is because all this legal
drama is going on behind the scenes
trying to work out deals with people
it's been reported though that this
Captain America deal is finalized like
it's gonna happen
they're not gonna rewrite the movie
again I do like the thought that they've
rewritten it a couple times already like
he was in the movie then a studio boss
ordered him out so they wrote him out
and then they wrote him back in it's
crazy the other really interesting thing
is if Chris Evans is gonna sit out
Avengers 3 does that mean someone else
is gonna take the mantle of Captain
America right now I would say my leading
candidate would be Anthony Mackie that's
basically what they did in the comics
Falcon took on the mantle of Captain
America right now just as we're getting
lady Thor like Marvel shuffling a lot of
characters around in their titles the
other thought is that they would make
Bucky Captain America they've done both
things in the comics both the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier separately on
separate occasions have been Captain
America let me know what you would
rather see though would you rather see
the Winter Soldier
take on the mantle of Captain America or
would you rather see the Falcon become
Captain America and this is for Avengers
3 so this is still a long ways off
because this is still a really big deal
and they'll probably be reporting on
this for the next couple of days I'll do
a follow up to this story in my agents
of shield video tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get that and if you have
any big questions I might do a few Q&A
question
it's just because this is actually
really interesting to talk about if you
guys are interested in like the business
E Hollywood side of all the superhero
movies just let me know and I'll include
it in my future videos I find it very
fascinating but sometimes people find it
boring
right now though click here for a
breakdown of the Avengers 2 trailer from
comic-con
and click here to learn about Captain
Marvel maybe being in the movie thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high five and just peek out a little bit
at the thought of Ironman being in a
Captain America movie
you